hello everyone since a lot of you were
sad I didn't put any photo challenges in
my a couple of previous videos I did
prepare a quite a difficult one for this
video and I will not always have a photo
challenge for example now I'm holding
the call sign on and the World Chess
Championship Series I don't think I will
be doing any photo challenges there but
I will always try to show at least an
interesting photo or two now but since
this is a well it might turn out into a
miniseries but not not and it's not you
know meant to be a series so here it is
best luck best of luck to everyone let's
check it out
so here is your challenge and if you
need a hint or two at least one of these
gentlemen were world champions but
perhaps even two so there we have it
best of luck to you all and before we
start with this game
I recently learned of a very peculiar
hobby that 11r neon has I'm not really
sure if I should call it a hobby I'll
just show you what I mean so look at
this photo this is 11 Oregon and this is
what a very not the greatest photo shop
of of his dog panchak but it's a it's a
hobby 11 Arlen has he's the one that
actually made this photo he will use he
will use some historic above historic he
will use some photos that seem to be
important to him and then he will edit
his dog panchak onto the face of someone
else this is actually Maxine for Sheila
Grove and they're 11-hour and made this
on his smartphone so he I don't think he
posts them online but he probably has
like a whole lot of albums that he had
that he put panchak instead of some
other people and yeah as you can see for
example here is a photo from 11 Arnold's
wedding there's a little pond chick
really enjoying the day you know being a
part of everything at all so just you
know I found that really interesting
just wanted to share that with you guys
so about this game and about this
tournament here are the players from
this tournament it's this is the first
tournament that's a part of the Grand
chest or it's
your next move it's played in Leuven in
Belgium and this is a photo taken in
front in front of the playing hall where
the tournament is being held there you
have it
I wish seanathon11 Aragon Hikaru
Nakamura Wesley so uh nigiri in the
middle then there's Fabi maxima Sheila
Grouch acrimony er of Segway Kuryakin
and Alexander Grichuk so the last year's
champion of lumen tournament was Magnus
Carlsen there will be a rapid and blitz
event and since Carlson is not will not
be joining them in this this this year's
Leuven event then he will not be able to
defend his title but Wesley so had a
very nice start in in day one three
rounds were played so let's check out
one of the games this is a game Fabiana
Caruana versus obviously so we don't
have a photo of them actually playing
but we do have a nice close-up of Wesley
from this tournament there you have it
and a very nice close-up of folly so
let's let's check it out
Wesley has the black pieces and Fabi
opens with E for we have E 5 Knight to
f3 knight c6 and Bishop to b5 so the
rule opus a6 more fees defense brush up
to a 4 Knight to f6 we have castles
Bishop to e7 b3 b5 Bishop to b3 this is
all standard theory of more fees defense
b6 we have a for Bishop to d7 and c3 now
Wesley castles Bishop the c2 rook to e8
and rook to e1 h6
Knight b3 to be for now and d4 rope to
be eight b5 now attacking the knight be
captures on c3 and now B captures on c3d
captures on c6 is not possible due to
obvious reasons if you do this then
captures and you cannot capture the
bishop as rook is captured with check
Queen captures and after Queen captures
d7 black will be up the exchange you
will have a rook for a bishop
so after B captures on c3 be recapture
some B on C 3 and now Knight to a5
pressuring B 3 C 4 and also preparing to
put forward the C pawn bishop to a3 we
have C 6 C for now
Queen to C 7 developing the Queen
connecting rooks Bishop to d3 Knight
back to b7 and the 9th to b3 now and a5
Bishop to c1 we have Bishop to g4 and
now Bishop to e3 maneuvering from a3 2 e
3 9 3 7 and here Wesley is preparing a
very nice maneuver that is nice to see v
h3 Bishop captures Queen captures and
now comes Knight B to C 5 first our
Wesley will double his pawns but only
temporarily and as you will see he will
get a great compensation for it
we have captures captures captures D
captures on c5 and now Bishop to f1
Wesley now controls the B file and it's
very hard to oppose him if you play
something like rook eat to be one then
rook to be 4 is coming rook to b4 is a
move that will be played eventually a
regardless of what white plays it's a
you know free doubling up of the rooks
or Blackwell or or white will capture
and black will very nicely on double and
have a nice connected a and B pawn so
after D captures on c5 first Bishop to
f1 and now rook does come to be for
Bobby decided not to challenge Wesley's
control of the B file rook to d1 and now
rook eat the b8 of course doubling up on
the B file g3c capture son d5 now
getting rid of his a weak doubled pawn
he captures on d5 and Bishop to d6 now
as you can see Bobby has a light square
bishop Wesley has a dark square bishop
and usually when you have a light square
against the dark square bishop and there
are still queens and rooks on the board
what you want to do is you want to
attack your opponent because if if black
is on the attack and he's using his dark
square Bishop for attacks then a white
will not be able to oppose this Bishop
with his light square Bishop so it will
be like one of the players that the one
who's attacking is attacking being a
piece up something you know maybe worth
remembering but as for now this Bishop
is currently currently a pawn so e4 will
have to be played at some point and it
will be it will be seen if Bobby can
activate his lights
so h4 Queen to d7 Wesley would very much
enjoy pushing f5 so far B doesn't talk
about the Bishop to d3 g6 again Wesley
wants to push a 5 and 5 B once again
doesn't allow at the g4 so this desktop
f5 but this is a lot of open space in
front of the White King Queen to e7
we have h5 now and Queen to g5 h capture
son g 6f capture son g6 and now Queen to
g2 it's not all that easy to untangle
for white here as the the g2 pawn has to
be defended the Queen isn't really
useful on f3 this rook can easily come
to a fate the other row can come to be
too you don't want to move the Queen so
you can maybe pull the F point further
protect the g4 pawn but it's not at all
simple Fabi plays Queen to g2 we have
looked to f8 now rook to e1 and now
comes Rock to b3 attacking the bishop
rook to e3 now defending the bishop and
also the rook will come in very handy in
defending the King side rook to f4
now with ideas of playing rook captures
on g4 Bishop to f5 now can seemingly a
piece sacrificed but not really as this
did open up the attack from white rook
to the black rook and now you could
capture for example rook captures on e3
and after F captures simply wrote
captures on c4 you could grab bone and
you know this Bishop has to move okay
Bishop e6 check but what it doesn't
really have anything here but instead
after this Bishop to a5 rope the b2 is
played Wesley simply keeps on the
tension bunch of to e6 check King to g7
and now comes rope to f1 you don't have
to protect the F pawn somehow you either
look to f3 or rook to f1 what favi
played is is is a an okay move so look
to f1 and now rook captures on c4 there
was no way to deal with both threats so
here Wesley wins a clean pawn we have
twin to g3 of course you can't allow
this pond to be captured so Queen to g3
rugby to before now two rooks and the
Queen are attacking this pawn
and we have queen 2h2 simply getting the
queen out of the way f3 is no longer
possible because then simply Queen
captures rock with check so cling to h2
and now rock to f4 yet again
Wesley keeps the pressure you know on
rock characters on g4 is also possible
but it is a rapid game you don't want to
give your opponent any chances
this comes with check and after Bishop
captures rook captures after King moves
now
efore is the move now you finally open
up the dark square bishop you have to
sacrifice it and after Queen captures
now rope to h4 check Queen blocks and
now rock capture screen captures and
Queen captures on d5 you have a queen
against two rooks but with being up
three points this would be winning for
black but the Wester doesn't want to
give any chances
rook to a four and now Wesley prepares
efore King to h1 we have E for now now
the bishop will be eyeing the Queen as
as soon as the rook moves f3 got a
further guarding the g4 pawn but now h5
Queen h3h captures on g4 Bishop captures
on g4 and now there's really little
white can do here black can either go
look b2 rook b8 rook f8 pretty much any
move will do in the game fabulous ID to
go rogue b8 with the thread beam rope to
h8 winning the Queen so Fabi plays Queen
to g3 but now comes Rock to h8 with
check King moves and here of course
everyone can see the move okay
either he captures on f3 this will also
be nice this comes up with check but in
the game rookie actress Angie for was
played and it was in this position that
Fabiano Caruana World Chess Championship
Challenger resigned the game why did he
resign well of course he just lost the
piece and he will lose his Queen he
cannot capture the bishop here as the
Queen is pinned and of course if you
play something like f captures on g4
then the bishop will capture Queen and
there's really no counter play here
since the Queen captures rook and white
is getting checkmated here so yeah after
this rook to g4 a very nice move Fabiana
resigned the game and a very nice win
for Wesley soul
and just so we don't forget here are the
standings after day one so after three
games were played Wesley so is currently
in first place with two and a half out
of three points and then followed by car
cane and Ariane with two points with one
and a half points Nakamura Grisha Sheryl
graph and onigiri and mama D are off and
in last place with only half out of
three points are Vishwanath and Ireland
and Fabiano Caruana so a lot of people
are saying that if you know Fabiano has
to definitely okay this is only day one
but you know as people like to talk they
say that he should definitely improve
his game especially a rapid and blitz
game because if you know he will not be
able to defeat Magnus in November in
classical time format or you know after
all the games are played if it's gonna
be at raw then they will go into rapid
format and end in the end the Blitz
format so he with this with this you
know the level of play he will not pose
much challenge the caution in in
November so yeah that's that's the game
and those were some nice photos I do
hope you enjoyed that little story about
Aaron Scobie as well and best of luck in
the photo challenge I would like to
thank once again Douglas rife Kyle
Pascoe thing wrong
Michael Michael and the William Fusco
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here think'll for watching and I
will see you soon perhaps with another
nice rapid game from woven or we'll see
if none of the games will be very
interesting we'll just continue with our
unendorsed carlson series and if you
found any game in particularly
interesting you know feel free to
suggest from Leuven and I will I will
definitely check it out so yeah thank
you all and I will see you soon